DOCTOR WEBER NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
POWER QUE HAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO
BURKE CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAO GEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY THE EGGMAN
FLORA WRONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL EDISON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS LOOSE REEBOKS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE DEAN.
WELL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. DAYS PRAYER. WILL BE
OFFERED BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER MISTER JONES
SAWYER. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
LET US PRAY LORD WE HAVE
GRANTED IT TODAY IN YOUR HONOR
AND THROUGH YOUR BLESSING WE
ARE ABLE TO BE HERE SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE. WE
ALL HAVE TAKEN DIFFERENT PATHS
TO BE HERE TO SERVING YOUR
HONOR ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
EVEN THOUGH AT TIMES OF WORK IS
DIFFICULT WE MUST BE THANKFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
OUR DISTRICTS BECAUSE THERE IS
NO HIGHER GLORY THEN SERVING
OUR COMMUNITIES. AS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IT IS WITH GREAT
HONOR THAT I ASKED THAT WE TAKE
A MOMENT TO PRAISE THE WORK OF
THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY. THEY
MAKE THE SACRIFICE EVERY DAY BE
OF SERVICE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
REAL HEROISM IS SHOWN THROUGH
SERVICE TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
NEED. TO REFLECT ON THE MEANING
OF THE WORK OF OUR ON SUN
HEROES. AS SERVANTS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THE CONNECTION
IT HAS TO OUR WORK HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL. LET US PRAY OVER
OUR AND SOON HEROES LET'S PRAY
THAT THEY WILL NOT TIRE IN THE
WORK AND THAT THEY WILL HAVE
THE ENERGY YOU TOO CAN YOU TO
DO THE HARD WORK THAT IS. TO
SAY. IN OUR COMMUNITY. THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
BLESS THIS THROUGH THEIR
SERVICE LET'S PRAY THAT ALL OF
OUR UNCERTAIN HERE'S CONTINUE
TO GATHER STRENGTH THROUGH
THEIR FAITH AND TO BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE A COMMUNITY THAT LOOKS
OUT FOR ONE ANOTHER LASSEN LET
US PRAY THAT OTHERS WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR A REASON TO SIR AND
LOOK TO THOSE HEROES AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT IT MEANS TO BE OF
SERVICE TO THEIR COMMUNITIES. A
MAN. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER COOPER. MR COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND WHICH IS. CAPTION IT IS A
LITTLE. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
FIFTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THESE
WOMEN AT SEVEN AM WE ARE WILL
COVER COUNTY SALINAS ECSTASY
PRESIDING SHE PUT THE
SUPERMARKET THE DESK
REPROGRAMMING LOSE RECALL THIS
LATER ON ONE OF ALL AROUND.
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN. FOR MATERNITY
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIR BONTA
S. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WEBER LEVINE
GIPSON AND PETRIE-NORRIS TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON LEVINE AND
PETRIE-NORRIS IS GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT THEIR DESK. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AND BURKE
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN MEMBER
TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS WITH US. ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
I SEE YOU HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESS INTRODUCTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING MEMBERS
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
TO THE FLOOR TO ASK YOU PLEASE
WELCOME MY YOUNGEST SON JORDAN
TO THE FLOOR THE- STATE CAPITAL.
AND MISS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU HAVE
GUESTS WITH YOU AT YOUR DESK
TODAY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I VERY SPECIAL GUESTS
JOINING ME TODAY I'M REALLY
PLEASED TO HAVE MY TWO BOYS
HERE. DILLON IS TWELVE AND HATE
IN JUST TURNED ELEVEN PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM TO
THE FLOOR TODAY.
AND MR LEVINE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR INITIAL GAS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SAID DURING
THE LAST WEEK OF SESSION YOU
HEARD. MY SON WHILE LEVIN'S
NAME BECAUSE THAT WAS THE WEEK
THAT HE HAD HIS BAR MITZVAH AND
TODAY I BRING THE BAR MISTER
BOY HIMSELF- TO JOIN US FOR THE
DAY THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE SPECIAL CEREMONY IN
HONOR OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM SIX. ACR ONE FIVE
FIVE. FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING. MR GIPSON WILL OPEN ON
BEHALF OF DOCTOR WEBER MISTER
GIBSON ARE YOU READY TO PROCEED
ON THIS ITEM. THE CLERK WILL
READ A C. R. ONE FIVE FIVE SO
THE GRANT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER WEBER
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. MISTER GIBSON
YOU MAY OPEN ON THE MEASURE
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. SHE
GOOD MORNING MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE RISE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AC ONE FIFTY FIVE
RECOGNIZING FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
AS BLACK HISTORY MONTH BLACK
HISTORY IS AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND SHOULD BE REMEMBERED AS
SUCH THE COUNTLESS
CONTRIBUTIONS AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE MADE TO OUR NATION-
EMBODIES A STATEWIDE STATE RAY
OF DISCIPLINES FROM SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ACADEMIA THE
GOVERNMENT AND OCIAL
LEADERSHIP THIS MONTH MORE THAN
EVER. LET US CELEBRATE THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING THE
PERSEVERANCE THROUGH THE DARK
TIMES IN AMERICAN HISTORY THEIR
EFFORTS OPEN DOORS FOR ALL
AFRICAN AMERICANS. HOWEVER
THERE FIGHT DOES NOT IN UNTIL
JIM DISCRIMINATION THEY FACE IS
ALSO A THING OF THE PAST DR
MARTIN KING JUNIOR LED THE
PROTESTS OVER THE PETTUS
BRIDGE. BECAUSE THE FIGHT WAS A
VOTING RIGHTS WAS IN SELMA ROSA
PARKS STARTED A MOVEMENT BY
REFUSING TO GIVE UP HER SEAT
BECAUSE THE FIGHT WAS IN
MONTGOMERY ALABAMA. DOCTOR
SHIRLEY WEBER WHO FOUGHT THE
CHANGE FOR CHANGE OF USE OF
FORCE STANDARDS THE FIGHT IS
HERE AUTUMN BURKE WHO MADE CHAU
POVERTY ISSUE BECAUSE THE FIGHT
IS HERE. MISTER KEVIN MCCARTY
WHO WORKED ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. BECAUSE THE FIGHT IS
HERE. THESE MEMBERS ALL ALONG
WITH MY CAR. ARE FIGHTING TO
CARRY ON LEGISLATION AND ALSO A
LEGACY BECAUSE THE FIGHT IS
HERE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH AND COMMIT
YOURSELVES TO THE FIGHT.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT
I VOTE ON ACR ONE FIFTY FIVE
BECAUSE THE FIGHT IS HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON IF
THERE ANY MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE MEASURE PLEASE
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES. DR ED
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK UGH THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A MEMBERS- TODAY I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS.
BUT AS I RISE ON BEHALF OF
LATINO CAUCUS I THINK ABOUT
INTERSECTION MELANIE BECAUSE AS
WE LOOK AROUND THIS FLOOR IN
THIS CHAMBERS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
LOOK LIKE A BLEND OF WHAT IS
EVERYTHING IS BEAUTIFUL ABOUT
CALIFORNIA IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. I COULD STAND YOUR
MEMBERS AS A MEMBER OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS AND I CAN TALK ABOUT
THOSE STRIDES WE'VE MADE BUT I
CAN ALSO TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE. WILL BE NO
THAT L. G. ESPECIALLY OF PEOPLE
OF COLOR BROWN AND BLACK FACE
GREATER RISKS OF MURDER. OF
RAPE. POVERTY THAN ANY OTHER
GROUP I COULD STAND HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND SPEAK ABOUT HISTORICALLY
HAD IS BEEN BLACK AND BROWN
WOMEN THAT HAVE RALLIED BEHIND
THE EFFORTS OFTENTIMES IN
SILENCE WE CAN THINK ABOUT
PEOPLE LIKE ROSA PARKS WE CAN
THINK ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE THE
LOWER SWEAR TO. WE CAN THINK
ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE SHIRLEY
CHISHOLM WE CAN THINK ABOUT IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY A PATRICIA
HATTON AN OBGYN CLINICIAN WHO'S
BEEN WORKING WITH BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE HER ENTIRE LIFE
BUT TODAY I STAND ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS AND I THINK
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE STILL WE'VE
MADE HUGE STRIDES OFTEN BEHIND
THE SCENES A LOT OF TIMES IN
FRONT OF THE STANDS. AND I
THINK ABOUT THE ISSUES AGAIN OF
INTERSECTION AUDI WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
WE KNOW THAT BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE LIVE IN AREAS WHERE
POLLUTION IS HIGHER WE KNOW
THAT BLACK AND BROWN EOPLE
LIVE IN AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE
LESS ACCESS TO WATER WE KNOW
THAT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
OFTEN LIVE IN ZIP CODES THEY
DIE SOONER THAN THEIR CALL
THANKS HELLO THIS IS NOT THE
BINDER BY SOCIOECONOMIC BUT
OFTEN JUST ON ISSUES OF RACE.
SO AS WE STATE SO EIGHT BLACK
WE STAND FOR YES THAT IS HEARD
THE PER THAT HAS MADE THE PATH
THAT WE CAN TO STRIVE AND WE
THAT WE MAKE THOSE BY BEST
GOING WITH WHO'S WHO FOR THE
SAME SITUATION THAT WE FACE
WHEN WE AND WITH OUR- BROTHER
SISTER ARE LOOKING OVER THE
SERBS THE WOMEN OF ALL DâN ALL
OF US TOGETHER SO I BY SIDE BE
WE KNOW. GATHER MEMBERS WE STOP.
MATH FOR OTHERS TO CONTINUE THE
PATH THAT WE- WILL HELP LAY. ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON ACR
ONE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR EGGMAN MISTER CHIU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I ALSO RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE P. I. LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
FIFTY FIVE. EVERY FAVOR A WE
REFLECT AND RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES THE LEGACY
THE STRUGGLES THE CHALLENGES.
ARE BUT LIKE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON- MANY OF US ALSO THINK
ABOUT THE INTERSECTION ALLEY OF
THESE ISSUES. ONE OF MY
FAVORITE EVENTS IN MY DISTRICT
DURING THIS MONTH IS A
CELEBRATION OF BLACK HISTORY
MONTH WITH THE CHINESE LUNAR
NEW YEAR. AND IT'S NOT JUST A
CELEBRATION OF CULTURE IT'S NOT
JUST TO SPUR CELEBRATION OF
SOCIAL COMMUNITIES. IT'S A
RECOGNITION THAT BEFORE THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT AND THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN INTERNMENT
THERE WAS SLAVERY THERE WERE
JIM CROW LAWS. THE FACT THAT
OUR STRUGGLES ARE INTERLINKED
THE FACT THAT THE TRIUMPHS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE REFLECTED.
IN HISTORY BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. I WOULD NOT BE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR AN
ORGANIZATION IN SAN FRANCISCO-
ROOTED IN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. THAT DECIDED TO TAKE
IN A LAW STUDENT I SOME TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO AN ORGANIZATION
WHERE I WORKED CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY. THOSE OF US THAT
REPRESENT DIVERSITY OFFICE BODY
WE WOULD NOT BE HERE BUT FOR
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT BUT
FOR THE RIGHTS FIGHT LED BY OUR
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERS. AND
HE NOT ONLY ARE COMMEMORATING
HISTORY BUT WE ARE COMMITTED
ARE SO. WE HAVE ECONOMIC. FOR
ALL HEALTH CARE FOR ALL.
EDUCATION FOR ALL IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
WORKS FOR ALL SO WITH THAT ON
BEHALF OF OUR API IT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. I STRONGLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER TO
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AS THE
LEADER OF THE ASSEMBLY
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FIFTY
FIVE HONORING BLACK HISTORY
MONTH. THE STORY TO A
REMARKABLE INDIVIDUALS AND
COUNTLESS CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
SOCIETY AND TO CIVIL RIGHTS BY
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
ARE SO NUMEROUS AND HAVE
POSITIVELY IMPACTED OUR NATION
IN FACT THEY ARE TOO NUMEROUS
TO MENTION ALL HERE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DEDICATE THE
MONTH OFFEBRUARY EACH YEAR TO
STUDYING RECOGNIZING AND
CELEBRATING BLACK HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION. AND CHEN
AYE VOTE ON THIS ACR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE DOCTOR WEBER
YOU MAY CLOSE. MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS- I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR- CELEBRATING
THIS PARTICULAR ACR. WITH THE
STATEMENTS BY THE VARIOUS
CAUCUSES CONCERNING WHAT THIS
MEANS TO YOU AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO ALL OF US. YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN- EIGHT YEARS. SINCE I
BEGAN DISCUSSING BLACK HISTORY
ON THE FLOOR OF THIS HOUSE. AND
I BEGAN TO ASK MYSELF AFTER ALL
THOSE YEARS WHAT CAN I SAY TO
YOU TODAY. THAT IS DIFFERENT.
MY FRIENDS OFTEN TEASE ME
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN A UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR AN EDUCATOR FOR FORTY
EIGHT YEARS. AND THEY SAY EVERY
TIME I OPEN MY MOUTH I'M ALWAYS
TEACHING FOLKS SOMETHING. IT'S
IN MY DNA IT'S WHO I AM. AND SO
I FIND IT DIFFICULT NOT TO.
HOPEFULLY SHARE SOMETHING WITH
YOU THAT'S IMPORTANT. BUT AS I
THINK ABOUT THE EIGHT YEARS
THAT WE HAVE HAD A CONVERSATION
HERE ABOUT BLACK HISTORY. I
THINK OF ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT. I THINK BE
CONSTANT EFFORT TO SAY TO YOU
OVER AND OVER HOW IMPORTANT
HISTORY IS IN AMERICA. THAT IT
IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF CHARACTER
IS NOT JUST THE GIVING OF
INFORMATION. BUT IT'S REALLY
THE SHAPING OF THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY. AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT ONE'S INCLUSION.
AND ONCE EXCLUSION FROM HISTORY
SPEAKS VOLUMES BUT THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND FOR THEIR FAMILY
AND WHO THEY ARE IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
THAT AND WE ASK OURSELVES THE
CONSTANT QUESTION WHY IS THIS
EXCLUSION STILL THERE. WE HAVE
TO ASK WHAT WAS THE INTENT IN
THE FIRST PLACE FOR THE
SOLUTION. AND AS WE LOOK AT IT
THEN WE CAN SEE THE IMPACT THAT
IT HAS ON PEOPLE'S
POSSIBILITIES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. AND THEIR
CHILDREN'S POSSIBILITY IN
OPPORTUNITIES. SO WE'VE HAD SO
MANY DISCUSSIONS CONCERNING
THAT. I'VE ALSO ASK YOU TO
WONDER WHAT THE WORLD WOULD
LOOK LIKE. IF WE HAD KNOWN
CERTAIN BITS OF HISTORY. IF WE
HAD KNOWN ABOUT THE HIDDEN
FIGURES. WOULD WE BE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT WOMEN BEING IN
STEM BECAUSE WOMEN WOULD
PROBABLY ONLY STEM. AND SURELY
WOMEN OF COLOR WOULD OWN STEM
IN OWN SCIENCE. SO THE LACK OF
THAT INFORMATION- THAT
MISINFORMATION OF NOT BELIEVING
THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO HAVE
A ROLE IN MATHEMATICS AND
SCIENCE. HAS CAUSED US TO SPEND
LOTS AND LOTS OF MONEY OF
TRYING TO TELL WOMEN YOU CAN DO
MATH. YOU CAN DO SCIENCE. WHEN
THEY THE OWNERS OF IT. AND THEY
SHOULD BE THE ONES DRIVE IT.
AND WE ASK WHAT WOULD THE WORLD
LOOK LIKE IF WE HAVE CERTAIN
THINGS THAT WOULD BE. AND I
EVEN ASK MYSELF AND MY STAFF
CONSTANTLY WHEN I'M TALKING
ABOUT HISTORY I WENT RECENTLY
TO SEE. THE MOVIE. AND I CAME
BACK AND I SAID WHAT DO THINK
ABOUT IT AS A HISTORIAN I BEGIN
TO TALK ABOUT THE ACCURACY OF
THE MOVIE I THOUGHT IT WAS
ACCURATE I THOUGHT IT WAS A
GOOD MOVIE. AND ONE OF MY
MEMBERS SAID TO ME YOU KNOW
HOW. THEY HAD A THEY HAD
FRIENDS WHO DIDN'T LIKE HERE.
THEY SAID WHY. SAID BECAUSE
WHITES HAD A ROLE IN IT AND
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT WHITE
PEOPLE. WHAT ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE.
AND I ONCE AGAIN HAD TO REMIND
THEM THAT THE HISTORY OF THE
UNDERGROUND RAILROAD. WAS NOT
JUST ABOUT BLACK DETERMINATION
TO BE FREE. BUT WAS ALSO ABOUT
THE COLLABORATORS THE WHITES
WHO COULD NOT STAND THE SYSTEM
AND FOUND WAYS TO PARTICIPATE.
AND IF THEY HAD KNOWN THEIR
HISTORY AND HAD LOOKED UP A
BOOK LIKE WITHOUT SANCTUARY
ABOUT LYNCHING OF THIS COUNTRY.
THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN PICTURES
OF WHITE MOTHERS AND WHITE
CHILDREN LYNCHED ALONG SIDE OF
BLACK INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE THEY
WERE SYMPATHIZERS. THE WHITE
SOMETIMES RESTED THEIR FAMILIES
THE RESOURCES SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY COULD NO LONGER STAND IN
AN UNJUST SYSTEM. AND IF WE
KNOW THAT. THAT MIGHT MOTIVATE
US SOME POWER TO LOOK FOR OTHER
COLLABORATORS IN COOPERATORS
AND OTHERS TO STAND WITH US. ON
ON THE ISSUES THAT ARE SO AND
JUST. THAT'S WHY I APPRECIATE
SO MANY OF YOU ONE THREE NINE
TWO. BECAUSE 85% MEANT THAT
MOST OF US WERE NOT AFRICAN
AMERICANS WOULD NOT IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES SOLVE THE INJUSTICE
AND DECIDED TO STAY AT. IT'S
ALL BECOMES IMPORTANT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HISTORY THAT WE HAVE
ALL OF THAT. AND SO AS I THINK
ABOUT WHAT AM I GOING TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY. ABOUT HISTORY. AND
THEN I HAD TO REMIND MYSELF
WHAT I TOLD YOU LAST YEAR. I
LIVE FOR THE DAY. WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE BLACK HISTORY MONTH. WHEN
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS NO MORE
THAN A HISTORICAL STATEMENT OF
WHAT WE USED TO DO. THAT WE
WANT CELEBRATED HISTORY FOR
JUST A MONTH. BUT LOOK AT IS
NOW. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A
CURRICULUM. THAT ENCOMPASSES
ALL OF CALIFORNIA. THAT REALLY
PROVIDES FOR US THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO
GROW AND TO DEVELOP. AND I KNOW
THAT SO IT SEEMS LIKE A PIE IN
THE SKY. BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN HAPPEN IN MUST HAPPEN
IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO I THINK
OF THAT BECAUSE I THINK OF TWO
BILLS THAT YOU WILL SEE THAT
YOU HAVE SEEN. AND I LOOK AT
THE CONFLICT AND THE ISSUES
THAT ARE THERE IN THOSE BILLS
THAT HAVE NOT COME ABOUT. AND
WE REALLY MUST ASK OURSELVES
VERY HONESTLY WHAT IS THE FIRST
STEP WE TAKE. OBVIOUSLY THE
FIRST STEP WE TAKE IS TO
BASICALLY LOOK AT OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND SAY ARE WE
PREPARING OUR TEACHERS. TO
EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN SO THEY
HAVE THE COMPLETE PICTURE OF
HISTORY AND NOT JUST A PIECE OF
IT. AND IT TAKES TIME TO DO
THAT. BUT IT NEVER HAPPENS
WITHOUT THE FIRST STEP. AND SO
MY GOAL IN TERMS OF BLACK
HISTORY IS HAVING TAUGHT IT NOW
FOR FORTY EIGHT YEARS AS A
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR AND
CHAIRMAN DEPARTMENT AT A
NATIONAL PERSON. DEALING WITH
BLACK STUDIES. IS TO WORK SO
THAT WHEN WE TALK OF HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN WE TALK OF
HISTORY IN THE UNITED STATES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL OF US.
AND OUR CHILDREN ARE EMPOWERED.
BECAUSE THEY SEE NOT ONLY THE
STRUGGLE OF ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE
TO BE FREE. THEY UNDERSTAND THE
PRECIOUSNESS OF FREEDOM. AND
THEY ALSO SEE THEMSELVES IN THE
PROCESS OF MAKING IT HAPPEN. IT
IS A THING THAT IS NOW TIME
THAT WE STOP DOING THE
CELEBRATION ONCE A MONTH. A
BLACK HISTORY IN CHICAGO
HISTORY IN WHATEVER THAT WE
STOP DOING THAT. THAT WE MARK
THIS TIME SAYS THERE WAS A TIME
WHEN WE USED TO DO THAT. BUT TO
DAY. THIS TIME WE DO IT RIGHT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I
BOUGHT A NAY C. R. ONE FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR THAT POTENT
CLOSE DOCTOR WEBER. ALL THE BAY
HAVING CEASED WE WILL MOVE TO A
VOTE ON THE MEASURE THE FIRST
ROLL CALL WILL BE FOR CO
AUTHORS ON ACR ONE FIVE FIVE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR A CO AUTHOR. THERE
ARE SEVENTY TWO CO AUTHORS
ADDED. WE CAN TAKE OF LOS VOICE
VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
AS IS TRADITION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS TODAY WE SHALL RECOGNIZE
UNSUNG HEROES TO MARK BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. IN THE
INTERVENING YEARS SINCE THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES THE QUEST FOR
JUSTICE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND ALL AMERICANS HAS
CONTINUED. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
ESTABLISH THE UNSUNG HERO AWARD
IN HONOR OF DR KING TO
RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO EMBODY HIS
PHILOSOPHY AND IDEALS WE
CONTINUE THIS TRADITION WITH A
STELLAR GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE HONOR TODAY. I AM
APPOINTING AN ESCORT COMMITTEE
TO BRING OUR ANA REVIEWS ON TO
THE FLOOR FOR A SPECIAL
PRESENTATION MEMBERS SHOULD
RETIRE TO THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AS I CALL YOUR NAME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BURKE COOPER
GIPSON HOLDEN KAMLAGER JONES
SAWYER MCCARTY AND WEBER. YOU
I'M A RETIRED TO THE BACK OF
THE CHAMBERS. I ASK THE SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON REPUBLICAN
LEADER MARIE WALDRON AND C. L.
BC CAUCUS CHAIR SHIRLEY WEBER
TO MOVE TO THE CENTER I- TO
RECEIVE OUR HONOREES WE ARE
MOVING TO THE INTRODUCTION OF
THE UNSUNG HEROES. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY. THE ACCELERATED. THE
HONOREE FROM A SIXTY SECOND
DISTRICT THE SENDER ELLER
CAMPBELL SHE IS ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE
CINDERELLA CAMPBELL HAS BEEN A
DEDICATED EMPLOYEE FOR THE CITY
OF INGLEWOOD FOR THE PAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SHE WORKED
DIRECTLY FOR THE CHIEF OF
POLICE AS A SENIOR COMMUNITY
AFFAIRS HOMELESS LIAISON HER
DUTIES INCLUDE SETTING UP
NEIGHBORHOOD BUSINESS WATCH
MEETINGS RESPONDING TO AND
TROUBLESHOOTING THE CONCERNS OF
INGLEWOOD RESIDENTS PLEASE
WELCOME CINDERELLA CAMPBELL.
WE
OUGHT TO REFORM THE NINTH
DISTRICT AS MISTER CLIFTON WEST
THE THIRD HE IS ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER. MISTER
CLIFTON WEST THE THIRD IS THE
SON OF CLIFTON WEST JUNIOR AND
I READ THE WEST AND IS THE
OLDEST OF FOUR CHILDREN. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT HE WAS THE
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONAL
CHAMPION IN THE MILE RUN. IN
RECENT YEARS MISTER WEST HAS
WRITTEN A MEMOIR TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE SIGNIFICANT
EXPERIENCES FROM EARLIER IN HIS
LIFE. IT IS TITLED OF LIFE AND
TIME PLEASE WELCOME. MISTER
CLINTON WES.
THE ARMY FROM THE
SIXTY FOURTH DISTRICT IS
JASMINE CANTIK SHE'S ESCORTED
BY SOMEBODY. GIPSON JASMINE. IS
COMMITTED OR- CAREER TO TAKING
ON A COMFORTABLE AND HARD TO
DISCUSS ISSUES AROUND RACE.
POLITICS AND SOCIETY AND TELLS
IT LIKE IT IS. JASMINE IS KNOWN
FOR BRINGING ATTENTION TO
STORIES OF THAT WOULD HAVE GONE
UNDER REPORTED. OVERLOOKED OR
OTHERWISE IGNORED. PLEASE
WELCOME JASMINE CANTIK.
THE
ONLY REASON THE FORTY FIRST
DISTRICT REGGIE AND ONE A
WHERE. THERE WAS COURTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDER. REGIMEN
A WEBER SUCCESSFUL
ENTREPRENEURS COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES AND OWNER AND
OPERATORS OF SIXTEEN MCDONALD'S
RESTAURANTS. TOGETHER THEY'VE
ESTABLISHED A ROOT RENEE WEBB
SCHOLARSHIP FUND RENEE WAS
INDUCTED INTO MORE INTO THE
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS HALL OF FAME
AND SHE RAISED THREE HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. DURING
HER BOARD SERVICE RIGHT GIVE ME
SERVICE INCLUDES A UNIVERSITY
OF ALL OF OUR AND A LOS ANGELES
URBAN LEAGUE. PLEASE WELCOME
REGGIE AND WHEN THEY WERE.
YEAH.
THE HONOREE FROM THE FIFTY
NINTH DISTRICT AS DR CENTER ECO
SHE IS A SCORE BY MEMBER JOE
SAWYER DOCTORS EACH IS
CURRENTLY THE DIRECTOR OF THE
COALITION OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SHE WAS A TEACHER
IN SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST FOR THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT DR **** RECEIVE HER
UNDER WRITTEN UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES AND A
MASTER'S AND DOCTORAL DEGREE
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHE'S DONE FIELDWORK
IN CHILD PSYCHOLOGY CHILD AND
ADULT PSYCHOTHERAPY RECEIVE
SPECIALIZED TRAINING IN
CRITICAL INCIDENTS DEBRIEFING
PLEASE WELCOME DOCTOR SATCHER
****
THE ONE. WHAT. WE HONOR WE
FROM THE SEVENTH WORKERS CALL
PENSION HE IS ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REGARDING IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT CALL PICKS AND
FOUND THE BLACK PERIL SCHOOL
BOARD A COMMUNITY ORDER WORKING
TO THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP RESTORE EQUITY
FOR BLACK STUDENTS PLEASE
WELCOME CALL PINKSTON.
BONTA RE
FROM THE FIFTY FOURTH DISTRICT
LATER CALLED DENNIS SHE IS
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CAMERA. WE ARE CALLED IN
COLLABO WITH OR- FROM WATCHABLE
FOR THE WEST ADAMS AND ALL
ACROSS LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT
OF OUR COMMUNITY. THEY INCLUDE
THE BROTHERHOOD CRUSADE A LOS
ANGELES CITY COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN THE URBAN
LEAGUE AND DOUBLE ACP LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND. FOR FOCUS ON
EDUCATION AND FAMILY CARE IS
REFLECTED IN THE WORK WITH
GREAT BEGINNINGS FOR BLACK
BABIES THE SHELTERING ARMS HE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT UNION FOR
COMPTON AND HEAD START. SHE'S
ALSO WORK TO FOSTER AND PROMOTE
POSITIVE CULTURE IMAGES BY
PROMOTING BLACK ARTS BLACK FILM
SHE SELFLESSLY. THOSE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES PLEASE WELCOME
WIENER COLDER.
RIGHT FOR THE.
WE HONOR REFORM A SEVENTY NIGHT
DISORDERS DR RODNEY HOOD HE IS
ESCORTED BY SOME REMEMBER WEBER
DOCTOR RODNEY HOOD IS A BOARD
CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN OF INTERNAL
MEDICINE AND A LEADER IN THE
FIELD OF HEALTHCARE IN SAN
DIEGO HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN DIEGO NATIONAL MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AFFILIATE AND THE
GOLDEN STATE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HE REMAIN SOCIALLY
ACTIVE WITH MEMBERSHIPS AND
ALPHA PHI ALPHA SIGMA PI FIVE
LAY FRATERNITIES DOCTOR WHO IS
ONE OF THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO RECEIVE A MEDICAL
DEGREE FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. PLEASE WELCOME DOCTOR
ROBIN HOOD.
WHAT ON. YEAH THE.
ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
FOR THIS SPECIAL CEREMONY TODAY.
A MOMENTO IS ON YOUR DESK. IT
IS THE NINETEEN FORTY EDITION
OF THE NEGRO MOTORIST GREEN
BOOK. THE GREEN BOOK WAS A
LIFELINE AND A LIFE SAVER FOR
SO MANY TRAVELERS IN THE
SEGREGATED SOUTH DURING A TIME
WHERE RACE AND COLOR MATTERED.
WRITTEN BY VICTOR AGE GREEN IT
GUIDED AFRICAN AMERICAN
TRAVELERS TO A PLETHORA OF
ACCESSIBLE ORDINARY THINGS
NEEDED WHILE TRAVELING BY
LISTING HOTELS TAVERNS GARAGES
NIGHT CLUBS RESTAURANTS SERVICE
STATIONS AUTOMOTIVE TOURIST
HOMES. ROAD HOUSES BARBER AND
BEAUTY SHOPS. WHILE LIST SEEM
MONDAY INCLUSION IN THE GREEN
BOOK ASSURED PEOPLE THAT THEY
COULD SAFELY APPROACH UTILIZED
AND PATRONIZE THE BUSINESSES
LISTED WITHOUT FEAR FOR THEIR
PERSONAL SAFETY. OR AN ABRUPT
FOR FREE REFUSAL OF SERVICE
INDOOR ACCOMMODATION BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE. WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO TAKE A FEW MOMENTS TO
VIEW THE SPECIAL EXHIBIT ON
AFRICAN AMERICAN INVENTORS ON
THE FIRST FLOOR NEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AT YOUR
LEISURE IT WILL BE ON DISPLAY
THROUGH FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY. AS
OUR HONOREES EXIT THE CHAMBER
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ANOTHER ROUND
OF APPLAUSE FOR OUR HONOREES.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. ITEMS ONE TWO AND THREE
ON RECONSIDERATION ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. OKAY ON ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE ITEMS. FOUR
AND FIVE PASS AND RETAIN. AB
AND FILE ITEM SIX HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. FILE ITEM SEVEN
PASS. AND RETAIN. SENATOR RING
FILE ITEM EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS ANNOUNCEMENTS. SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
FLOOR SESSION IS AT TEN AM FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS. MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. WE
ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ORTEGA CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WE
ARE THE GERMANS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION. TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH. ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. IT IS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND GREGORY DEAN JENKINS
JUNIOR OF SAN JOSE. GREG LIVED
A LIFE FULL OF MUSIC. AS A
YOUNG TEENAGER HE ENTERTAINED
HIS COUSINS SINGING AND PLAYING
THE GUITAR AND A BANJO. IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHEN HE AND I WERE
FRIENDS. HE AND HIS FRIENDS HAD
A SUCCESSFUL DJ BUSINESS. THE
HOME OF HIS MOM AND DAD IS
WHERE THE GARAGE BAND
REHEARSALS HAPPENED. AND HE HAD
THE BEST HAIR AND THE BEST CAR
ANY COOL GUY IN THE EIGHTIES
COULD HAVE ASKED FOR. HE WENT
ON TO HOST A SATURDAY MORNING
MUSIC TALK PROGRAM ON THE LOCAL
AM STATION IN SANTA CLARITA. HE
ATTENDED HART HIGH SCHOOL AND
LATER COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS.
AND THEN WENT ON TO SANTA
BARBARA CITY COLLEGE AND UC
SANTA BARBARA. WHERE HE MET THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE AND HIS FUTURE
WIFE JENNIFER. AND ALTHOUGH
THEIR ROMANCE WAS SADLY ENDED
FAR TOO SOON. THEY SPENT A
REMARKABLE TWENTY NINE YEARS
TOGETHER. GREG IN JENNIFER
SETTLED IN SAN JOSE TO RAISE
THEIR FAMILY. WELL IN THE AND
GRAY CONTINUE TO PURSUE MUSIC
PERFORMING IN BANDS IN CLUBS
AROUND THE BAY AREA SELF
PRODUCING ALBUMS AND TEACHING
GUITAR. HE WAS ALSO TO HIS
GREAT JOY A STAY AT HOME DAD.
HE WAS FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE
TIME TO FORGE A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH MARY JANE AND
LUCAS WORKING IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS AS A PARENT
VOLUNTEER. HE WAS WELL KNOWN AT
WASHINGTON OPEN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL FOR CREATING ZERO THE
HERO TO CELEBRATE THE ONE
HUNDREDTH DAY OF SCHOOL EVERY
FALL TERM. WHATEVER WORK HE DID
HE BELIEVED IN THE DIGNITY OF
WORK. HE GAVE DRIVE DEVOTION
AND HIGH POWERED ENERGY TO
EVERY JOB HE DID. GREGORY LATER
IN LIFE WENT BACK TO SCHOOL TO
GET IS TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND
WENT ON TO TEACH ENGLISH CINEMA
AND MYTHOLOGY AT FOOTHILL
CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOL. HE
WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND TO BRING
IN REACHING PROGRAMS TO HIS
STUDENTS APPLYING FOR GRANTS
AND FIELD TRIP OPPORTUNITIES
AND HELPING OTHER TEACHERS USE
TECHNOLOGY IN THE CLASSROOM. AS
TOLD BY MANY INDIVIDUALS AT THE
MEMORIAL HELD FOR HIM AT FOOT
FOOT HILL HE WAS THE SPARK AND
THE INSPIRATION THAT MADE
THINGS HAPPEN. MAINTAINING
CLOSE FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS WAS
VERY IMPORTANT TO GREG AND HE
LEAVES BEHIND MANY AUNTS UNCLES
AND COUSINS WHO ALL LOVE HIM
DEARLY. HE NURTURE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH HIS FRIENDS
AND NEIGHBORS VOLUNTEERING HIS
TIME TO ASSIST IN HANDY MAN
PROJECTS AND SPREADING JOY WITH
HIS GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR. LAST
APRIL GREGORY WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH GASTRIC CANCER. AFTER A
DIFFICULT FOR MONTH BATTLE HE
PASSED PEACEFULLY IN THE EARLY
MORNING SURROUNDED BY HIS
FAMILY IN HIS OWN BED LISTENING
TO THE MUSIC THAT HE LOVED HE
WAS ONLY FIFTY ONE. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF TWENTY
THREE YEARS JENNIFER JINKINS
DAUGHTER MARY JANE WHO IS
NINETEEN SON LUCAS WHO IS
SEVENTEEN. HIS FATHER DR
GREGORY JENKINS MOTHER MICHELLE
JENKINS AND SISTER LORIAN.
GREGORY'S LOVED ONES JOIN US IN
THE GALLERY HERE TODAY FOR HIS
MEMORIAL AND WE WELCOME THEM.
GREG LIVED ACCORDING TO THE
TENANTS OF THE PROVERB. WHEN
YOU WERE BORN YOU CRIED AND THE
WORLD REJOICE. LIVE YOUR LIFE
SO THAT WHEN YOU DIE THE WORLD
CRIES AND YOU REJOICE. I ASK
YOU TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
MOURNING THE LOSS OF A GREAT
SON BROTHER FATHER HUSBAND
TEACHER AND FRIEND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH. THE
QUORUM CALL IS LISTED AT THIS
TIME. MS BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN A
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
JOURNEY MEMORY OF ORSON BEAN
WHO DIED AT AGE NINETY ONE WHEN
HE WAS STRUCK BY A CAR WHILE
CROSSING THE STREET IN VENICE.
MR BEAN WAS A BONAFIDE
HOLLYWOOD LEGEND WHO OVER IT
HAVING DECADE CAREER SHOWCASES
TOWNS AS A MAGICIAN. STAND UP
COMEDIAN AND RECKON TOUR IN
DOZENS OF FILMS TV AND STAGE
ROLES. SUCH AS TONIGHT SHOW
WITH JOHNNY CARSON AND THE
BROADWAY PRODUCTION SUBWAYS ARE
FOR SLEEPING WHICH EARNED HIM A
TONY NOMINATION. A BELOVED IN
TREASURE MEMBER IN THE
COMMUNITY OF VENICE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. MR BEAN AND HIS
WIFE ACTRESS ALLEY MILLS WOULD
FREQUENTLY OPEN THEIR HOME FOR
COMMUNITY GATHERINGS AND PEOPLE
IN NEED OF A PLACE TO STAY. HIS
LOVE FOR THE THEATRE IN
COMMUNITY MANIFEST ITSELF IN
HIS EFFORTS TO HELP FIND AND
BOLSTER THE NONPROFIT PACIFIC
RESIDENT THEATRE. ALONG WITH
LOCAL SCHOOLS AND LOCAL
BUSINESSES. THAT LOVE FOR HIS
COMMUNITY EARNED HIM MANY
AWARDS INCLUDING. VENICE AWAY
FROM THE ADVOCATING FELT THAT.
ASSOCIATE MY THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS ARE WITH HIS WIFE ALLEY
MILLS HIS CHILDREN AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN. THE MIX. NEVER
FORGOTTEN. THANK YOU AND ARE.
THEIR THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MS BURKE.
MEMBERS BRING THE NAME OF THE
DESK BE PRETTY IN THE CHURCH.
ALL REQUESTS TO ADJOURN MEMORY
WILL BE DAY READ. AND PRINTED
IN THE CHURCH. ALL OTHER ITEMS
FROM WILL PASSED TO RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING HER FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN MOTION. TO
ADJOURN. MR LACKEY MOVES MISTER
COOPER SECONDS THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY NINETEENTH.
AT TEN AM WE ARE JR.